this is a maybe an even stranger video
that i have to play for you today
uh there's this guy roger stone roger
stone was a former associate of donald
trump's he was charged he was convicted
he was pardoned by donald trump and you
know this week we've been going back and
forth about when mike pillow says these
crazy things mike lindell ceo of
mypillow does he believe them or does he
not and we looked at all sorts of
different evidence pointing one way and
pointing the other way
i genuinely have the same question with
the clip i'm about to play for you roger
stone appeared on some show who even
knows what it is let's let's see if we
can figure it out um he appeared on
elijah streams
which is some kind of religious show
okay and he said
that he has discovered that there's a
satanic portal at the white house and he
presents pictures which he claims proves
it now again my question is
is he for real or is he just cow towing
to whoever is interviewing him and in
this case it's a religious nuttery show
so he has to bring some religious
nuttery let's take a look see if we can
figure it out there you can see it uh
it's very very clear it doesn't move day
or night it's harder to see during the
day but you you see it at night
and
i'm absolutely convinced
about the inherent there it is again
about the inherent evil of what's going
on in the white house what's going on
in the country right and i think it's
imperative
that people know about this the people
of good faith that christians know about
this and we begin a national
essentially a prayer assault to close
the portal so i guess what he's pointing
to as the portal
if you're only listening there are
images where there's almost like a
smudge of some kind above the white
house
and it could be anything from i mean
quite literally a cloud
a lens flare i don't know it's very very
strange but i guess that's the portal
that um
he wants closed i don't know let's
continue to close the portal we were
born for this moment i haven't for sure
i've been preparing this for for this
moment my entire life without even
knowing it i just thought i was a
political warrior but this is no longer
a war in the political realm i for some
reason
i'm struggling to believe that this is
his genuine belief i don't know what you
guys think but it's it's just
it's just not feeling like he really
believes this crap that's right
and
and i do know how it comes out because i
know how the bible comes out but i don't
know exactly what the plan is but i do
know
that closing this portal is crucial to
victory right
and i want others to it's funny how
other people are nodding like this is
the first they've heard of this portal
but yet they're sure that it's crucial
to close it talk about it i want others
to see it you can look it up online you
can go to that live camera it's up every
night folks
down by the way i predict you they'll
now take it down so people can't see it
right but but this is not some practical
joke this isn't some conspiracy theory
i'm absolutely convinced that this is a
it's demonic it is a satanic portal uh
it is access to this earth uh by those
who are evil and only by closing it will
be will we be successful in saving this
nation
now one of the questions that to me
anytime i hear stuff like this i i just
there's questions that seem natural
right so like for example when i hear
about
noah's ark for example
and they say they were there's two of
every species a male and a female it's
like okay well
it might be plausible if you think of
like well giraffe and hippo and two
chickens and whatever else
but do you really understand what you
mean by two of every species we're
talking about two of every kind of snake
two of every kind of bird look at how
many different birds there are
two of every kind of little worm and two
it starts to be kind of like well is
that really feasible another question
about noah's ark what did the
carnivorous animals eat
because if you had two snakes and two
mice
snakes eat mice
so
did the mice survive well no we had two
of each type of mouse
plus extras for the snakes to eat
well but you didn't say that at first
the story is that there were just two
these are the types of questions that my
mind go to go to and so when i get to
this is a satanic portal for them to
come to earth
where are they coming from are we
talking about demons or are we talking
about aliens and if it's aliens where
did they come from and if it's demons
where do they normally live and why do
they even need a portal in other words
if demons are really ethereal and
omnipresent
why do you need a visible portal don't
they just appear particularly if they
are deputized by god with the sa it just
never makes sense and if you ask these
questions it's always
listen
we it's it's too complex for us to even
understand
god works in mysterious ways really well
if that's the case then why would they
use such a simple visible portal it
seems so obvious if you can see it why
wouldn't they come in a more discreet
way you'll never get answers to this
stuff good luck but you'll never never
get answers to this stuff my question
again is do you think roger stone is
sincere in this belief i don't think so
i think he knows this is nonsense i
think he is just uh placating whatever
audience he's in front of we have a
fantastic program for you today uh sign
up at joinpacman.com to get instant
access to the bonus show but we have so
much upcoming for you here
and then we have the bonus show and then
tonight i'll be streaming the trump
rally live from nebraska this one
doesn't start till 9 00 pm eastern i'll
go live at 8pm eastern so i hope to see
you then but we have a hell of a show
for you today
i love documentaries and i bet many of
you do as well and for documentaries i
go to curiositystream one of our
sponsors it's an app for your phone
tablet tv like netflix or hulu except
curiositystream has a way better
selection of documentaries because
curiosity stream only has documentaries
that's what they specialize in if you
are looking for the new award-winning
documentary they have it if you're
looking for classic documentaries they
have those they have a ton of great
original content always adding more to
the catalog i just watched
zenith which is about the latest
advancements in space travel a topic i'm
super interested in but there's
documentaries about just about every
topic imaginable i've been a curiosity
stream subscriber for several years now
it's my favorite app on my roku
and the best part of curiosity stream
it's 15 bucks a year
at curiositystream.com
pacman and the link is down below